- Hi, I'm Caitlin.
I'm gonna be talking a bit today
about data viz, data visualization
and the spread of COVID.
So, this is something
that pretty much everyone's
been inundated with
over the past year or so.
I feel like every day
there's a different version
of a graph surrounding COVID,
something about the virus,
some new way to break
down how it's spreading
and allowing us to kinda
talk about it a bit more.
And so, today I'm gonna
actually just break down a bit
how data viz and graphs in
general are sort of used
by society at large,
why they're being used at all,
and how people sort of
use different practices
to actually talk about
the spread of COVID-19.
So, first off,
I think really quickly to
start off this conversation,
data viz is this huge,
expensive sort of field,
but it touches on all
kinds of disciplines.
It's data science,
it's color theory,
it's design practices as well, right?
So it's intersecting a bunch
of different disciplines.
So I'm only gonna touch
on some of these aspects,
but just know that there's a
really broad and rich community
of people that work in data visualization.
But at its core,
data visualization is a way to communicate
and make sense of information.
And so, as people have been going through
this very challenging
global health crisis,
we crave narratives and stories
to process this information
and to help us understand
what's happening.
And so data visualizations,
allow us to make sense
of this massive information
we're being inundated with
really quickly and efficiently.
And so this is the main reason
why we would visualize
the spread of COVID-19.
And the first big example of this,
was the Flatten the Curve graphic.
There are couple versions of this,
this is sort of like
really nice cartoon version
that I liked that was put out early on
at the start of the
pandemic around March or so.
And it was meant to symbolize
how public health practices
like social distancing,
and staying home when sick
could prevent a surge in cases,
which would exceed the capacity
of our healthcare system,
so that's the sort of dotted
line is indicating here.
And this actual graphic
was a collaboration
between infectious disease
experts and illustrators
to convey what's actually
a very complex idea
as simply and clearly as possible, right?
There was a point to this, right?
It was to drive home
why adopting practices
like social distancing are so important,
and then ultimately,
sort of encouraging social responsibility.
We're not getting into the how
but much more of the why
of adopting the practices,
but that's the narrative of this viz,
and it's extremely compelling.
I'm sure most people have
interfaced with a version of this
and have heard this sort of
phrase, "Flatten the curve"
at multiple junctures,
especially early on during the pandemic.
If a visualization's generally,
it's purpose is to convey a narrative,
we have to remember
that there are many different
narratives out there,
some led by the data and
some led by an agenda.
And so there's a huge responsibility,
especially for something
like an epidemic or pandemic
in the way we communicate
information about it.
And so visualizations are powerful
for communicating information,
but they can also mislead, misinform,
and in worst cases
for something like a
disease, incite panic.
And so, we're in the middle
of this information overload
with hourly case updates,
endless streams of information.
So people are even more likely
to latch on to distilled viz, right?
We're already sort of primed
we need to have some sort of structure
amidst the chaos of info.
And so, we're ready to latch onto stuff
that just seems very simple.
Let me move myself out
of the way actually,
so you can see these wonderful...
I'm just gonna put myself in the midst
of this fun party.
I don't know if I would go
to dinner with these people,
but here we are.
Governor Cuomo in the
upper right of this page.
This is a screengrab, again,
early on in the pandemic.
He was doing these kind of
regular press briefings,
updating on the state of cases
and the spread of COVID in New York.
And so, this is a very
cluttered sort of table here,
but he is at least talking about
multiple different metrics.
Each one of these columns
is the different metric
including things like
hospitalization increases
over the past period of time,
I think he's talking about the past week,
ICU bed availability.
So, were space in
critical care facilities,
departments in hospitals,
rates of testing happening.
So there are many different
metrics he's comparing across,
and the kind of rows here
indicating different regions
of New York State,
but this is not comprehensive, right?
These are only a handful
of all possible important
metrics to consider
when deciding, for example,
as someone who's a policymaker
for the state,
where to allocate ventilator supplies,
or where to impose travel restrictions.
And these metrics were probably chosen
to support the Department of Health's plan
to classify different regions
as maybe a hotspot or not,
or a place where maybe
there is a higher need
for more ventilators
or something along those lines, right?
But again, this is not
something we maybe we think of
when we think of data viz,
but it is in a sense
a way to distill down a
lot of complicated data
into something that can
potentially build policy off of,
or for COVID response.
You can have tables with data,
but you can also distill things down.
Very commonly,
we saw a lot of bar charts
this year for COVID,
kind of comparing numbers across States,
across countries, across regions.
So, for example,
Trump in an interview for
Axios showed a bar chart
of deaths per cases.
So this is what was known
as the case fatality rate.
And, I don't know if you can
see this entirely well here,
but he's showing a bar chart
with four countries on there.
Obviously, there are more
countries in the world than four,
but he was showing this to indicate
that of these four that he showed,
United States had the
lowest case fatality rate,
which is fine.
That is probably true for
the four things he's showing,
but an important thing to note
is that the case fatality
rate is actually not helpful
in comparing countries.
And again, it's only
showing four countries.
Governor DeSantis, here from Florida,
also showed a similar metric.
In this case, he's actually
comparing different States
and the case fatality rate again.
Again, this is deaths by cases,
but for long-term care
facilities in a given state
with Florida being this very low one.
So, right?
Cases by deaths
is a metric to measure like many other.
You can kind of create a
fraction of whatever you want,
but a relevant statistic
would be something
that would normalize across
the different states, right?
The biggest difference
across different states
is the number of people in there.
So a simple way to kind of compare
across different places and regions
is to normalize it by population.
So a relevant statistic in this case,
instead of the case fatality rate,
would be a mortality rate
which is deaths by population.
And so that example,
again another bar chart,
this time flipped axes,
Dr. Birx, part of the White House team
for the coronavirus response.
Showing here again,
so the US having deaths
per a hundred thousand
and the kind of ranking there as well too,
across, again not every
country, select countries,
but this would be the kind
of more helpful metric
in this case.
And so, direct comparisons,
again population is not the only thing
that separates different
countries and places,
but you have to think of other aspects
like differences in public health systems,
demographic differences,
maybe a population
is older on average than another,
and the policy actions taken
at different points during
the pandemic, right?
So there are so many
potentially confounding factors
when representing data
and talking about kind of
takeaway points to compare
across different countries.
But the problem is,
here when a government official
shows the visualization,
the stakes are immediately
skyrocketing, right?
The audience typically doesn't think
to parse all the things I'm
kind of rattling on about,
and parse all of the different nuances
of what they're seeing.
That's just not the typical experience
of someone watching a press conference,
or watching a speech
or something like that.
The onus really should
not be on the audience
to sort this out.
It's on the creator of
the viz and the presenter
to provide context.
So, obviously this is the
most high stakes situation
of a politician or a government official,
talking about COVID in this way.
But unfortunately, putting
viz out into the public space,
kind of demands this
sort of responsibility
and requires it really.
And, we need clear data viz design
that doesn't mislead or misinform,
and importantly, it
doesn't add to the noise.
So, if you're thinking about
making public visualization
with COVID data,
you have to first ask yourself,
does this serve a need for the public
or uncover new information?
Because if it doesn't,
you really have to stop and think like,
"Maybe, I can work on
making a viz for myself,
"making a viz to like practice,"
which is always awesome thing to do
'cause a lot of this stuff
takes time to get good at,
but really think about
where you're sharing
and how things can be perceived
in a fully public sphere,
like something like social
media, or social media app,
or something like that,
because people might not perceive it
the way you might have spent
a lot of time thinking about
and all the nuances surrounding.
The kind of gist of what
you're probably getting
from me talking here is that
this is a hard thing to do
and get right.
And I should not make that
seem any easier than it is
because it's really difficult.
Visualizing and communicating uncertainty
which is fundamentally
the struggle here, right?
People are confused about
what's happening with pandemic,
is extremely difficult,
especially when the audience is primed
for straightforward answers.
People are like, "Okay."
"So where's it bad?"
"Where is it sort of okay to travel?"
And, people are trying to
operate in their day-to-day lives
and need to have clear answers
to guide their experience
on a daily basis.
And so this cartoon kind of
like summarizes that a bit.
It's actually a really
long fleshed out cartoon
that we have the link for on the site,
but this is from the viz
and science team at FiveThirtyEight.
And so here you can see, right?
People are stuck inside,
they wanna know like,
"How long are we gonna be locked in for?"
And given the sheer amount of data,
it's hard to come up with clear answers,
especially when data often
doesn't all kinda point
to one clear answer because
it almost never does.